se ci fosse veramente un titolo per
questo videogame dovrebbe tipo chiamarsi
cercare di non farsi beccare dal padre
mentre si guardano le cose sul computer
simulator hanno deciso di raccogliere
tutta questa merda di titolo l'anno
ristretto di brutto e l'hanno chiamato
basten
dopo questa premessa possiamo cominciare
a tutti ragazzi eve minuti ho visto un
video sono vari j
ed oggi siamo su cerca di non farti
beccare la tuo padre mentre di masturbi
sui computer simulator anche chiamato
basse ma quello sono io e mio padre sono
io che i baffi mio padre quanti cazzo di
anni a 800 ragazzi non sono sicuramente
io questo sarà mio padre era shumpert
new game sarà day one
mica tipo phinet freddi sa giornate c'è
il mio cane che è uscito a io sono
questo e computer sia perché il mio
carico team entrare o uscire in meta
ansia perché sto lanciando le noci
contro il computer mi spiegate ragazzi
sono cagato addosso giuro è stato
scoperto che non è vero ma non mi ha
procurato quanto è triste ma non mi ha
scoperto che tre mi fa paolo e stavo
girando le noci al computer ma non
possono anche ordinare non c'è computer
invece niente ragazzina moda di questo
gioco con papà vegas che invece di
entrare questo tizio coi baffi entra
papa vegas che ti becca mentre ti
masturbi ha quindi lo posso cambiare
schermata nuova geniale e quindi
studiare papa sta studiando dalla
scienza di db e dsi che tipo sempre non
ci credi ora che serio e papà perfetto e
che si può fare praticamente quando
disturbo tutti sti blocchi spunta un
immagine sexy il papa questo pesce non è
il mio ok sembrava impossibile
ci vogliono un miliardo quanto ci metto
per te fammi vedere le tette e veloce 6
se ancora più bello questo gufo bello
che begli occhi che ti ho fatto belli e
lo faccio viola faccio viola per cane
cane veloce però ci attira le noci oddio
ciò perché su un pc
c'è un buffo è la polvere [__]
volete spiegarmi perché mio padre mi
controlla mentre mi masturbo è il
problema che è successo questo di fiori
che voglio fare per la mamma più fatti
bene grazie
bene veloce veloce questo invece ai due
vi porti in vacanza
cazzo di un cane sexy quanto sexy questo
fiore bello proprio basta che l'orgoglio
nieri là sopra prima che è possibile in
quanto meno anche al 4 però che a due o
tre non sono anche contare è perché la
masturbazione rende ciechi
def a ping j che bello il piccione
mi spiegate che cazzo di senso già
questo gioco ragazzi vi prego vado
avanti quindi quadra grazie è stato
bello ma succede
vabbè dei due bar hanno fatto un cazzo
la cosa ora ho cliccato i fan a fan culo
ma [__] mi fa mica inizia da zero
ari stronzo come new game qualcosa new
game
siamo veramente ma ma ma va ma ed è lei
che mi spiega come si gioca fanta
fantastico se potessi uscire mentre che
se non entra mio padre voleva che già è
difficile spiegargli che guardo le foto
figurati se c'è una tettona incamera
click the block sull'autobomba lanci
lista non erano noci erano tette che
lanciava va bene allora niente non puoi
continuare in realtà c'è in base a
quanto riesci
non avevo capito che ne so sì però
parlare di sta calmo cazzo di un karma
poi chiude la porta a chiave porca eva
non c'è una chiave è normale non ho
capito
ok perfetto dei due allora serio e non
non entrare subito tua sorella
putrefatta mai veloce veloce te che
voglio vedere l'immagine è dato dall
armadio adesso non può uscir mio padre
dall'armadio vero ma perché c'è mica
solo non dormo più con delle tette le
tette perfetto tette che riguarda
ederson dette quelle che lanciò nuovo
mica capitolo che a sofia sesto gioco
che nella vita normale se qualcuno meno
male che vivo da solo
dopo sempre mette sempre i gufi io
disegno papà cosa vuoi un figlio cuffaro
ciao zia a posto
ci rivediamo è prodotta [__]
ascoltami rilancio delle teche però tu
puoi mostrarmi le tue vuole trovare
risultati su quanta gente che cazzo
quando mi masturbo che palle che tu che
si guardò mio padre entra in camera
bellissimo lo vorrebbero incazzato come
se se cosa vuoi
cosa vuoi vai dalla mamma a rompere i
[__] non perdiamo anche tu lo facevi
da piccolo cosa votato i giornaletti
tunca g caso sappiamo tutti che macchia
l'altro i ragazzi mi immagino una cosa
molto molto singolare che nel titolo del
video scriverò tipo a roba mio papà mi
mimì scopre mentre mi tocco una roba del
genere no
mio padre che aprirà youtube vedrà
scritto sul mio canale papà mi scopre
mentre mi tocco che cazzo va a pensare
che scusa papa non è come sembra e
meglio se ti spiego che mi stava
toccando veramente cioè più facile da
spiegare
basta basta papa che palle vai a seppi
che d'orgoglio ogni mare ma raiola
perfetto effetto che si fazzoletti non
li sprechiamo per niente dovrei fare
questo gioco in real life e vedere cosa
succede su un kart sukno nel senso che
anche su khyber cepu rate vabbè ma cos'è
davvero ad una bella showgirl
adesso c'è pure la tv mi spia così ce
l'avrete non posso non posso fare niente
dai che voglio vedere l'immagine
streamit e vabbè il gatto a ok ogni
tanto compare un
spieghi che problemi al cervello alla
dea tra l'altro la difficoltà è qua
sotto
com'è possibile come come fai essere in
due punti diversi che ti sia attraverso
la vita poi c'è anche una videocamera in
camera tra l'altro va beh adesso sto mi
esce dalla porta dalla soffitta e dal
televisore tutti insieme scommettete mi
metto a ridere veramente impossibile ma
io non ho capito dalle stelle in basso a
destra che cazzo sono le stelline di
difesa la difficoltà quella papa è
cascato qualcosa di là perfetto da dove
mi spia attraverso televisore basta mi
vede attraverso il televisore come fosse
che cazzo e samara the ring la
temperatura della cido deve essere
tenuta finché non capisce allora fiume
ok e come fa vedere se dall'altra parte
come fa vedere che cosa sto guardando
cosa non ho capito se mi vede con l'isef
se perdono nel dubbio io cambio sempre
proverà le rosse si le rosse con
però se le rose rosse per te un cazzo ma
va bene al nome di fare inizia
dall'inizio vi prego da [__] ah
che palle non posso stare 12 anni a fare
sto gioco è che mi piacevano sanità
mentale anch'io a cosa cazzo serve il
tasto continua in sto gioco me lo
spiegate vi prego praga vi giuro ska
parte veramente difficile mi che è
impossibile
porca eva è veramente difficilissima sta
roba perché ci mettono un ora
distruggersi sti blocchi di merda basta
papa che palle non puoi fare come tutti
i padri incazzati per la pagella che
cazzo vuoi ci sto mettendo 12 anni a
fini sto cazzo di credere per me avanti
papa sta squillando il telefono è per te
e per te veloce veloce che sta al
telefono veloce rossa di capelli golosa
di casa di pischelli 12 anni per fare
sta minchia di livello perfetto fissiamo
papa siamo io contro il tempo fa ok la
partenza 2 micai rossi ci metterò navara
[__] wi fi a meno almeno almeno da
capire che cos'è almeno da capire
l'immagine che cos'è niente niente
niente richiesto cliccando alla velocità
ma cosa fa il tg papa c'è il tg perfetto
né si esce anche hp basta ascoltare ogni
dove vedo delle tette re che bastava e
questa non capisco causa e vabbè cos'è
mica sono sorvegliato mammaria anche
l'ex via i
che palle ma sta tipa qua puoi uscire
anche dal soffitto che magari siamo a
posto ci abbiano land lei non è una
presa per il culo scherzavo
sconto di dio che ansia di vivere basta
basta basta
non posso fare un cazzo non posso fare
giacché tragedia che chi cazzo è questo
c'è la relativa di prima no è
leggermente pignocca va beh
scusa papa non volevo va bene ragazzi
direi che posso concludere qui
l'episodio è stato alquanto istruttivo
si quarto livello vuol dire che sono
esperto è cm vabbè c'è tanta roba
ragazzi miei spero che questo video vi
sia piaciuto concludo più episodio non
aveva un senso ma tanto ormai però che
siamo citano stesso mi è piaciuto sul
momento è un mi piace anche a pace di
facebook e coin interstiziale ci sono si
scrive ci vediamo il prossimo video
bella ragazzi